I remember when I was 21 my mom was in
County Jail and I was like visiting her
on my 21st birthday and it was a
strangest thing because like like
somehow she was ever like it it was it
was the oddest scene like I could see
this in a in a movie because she said
I've got the guards to convince the
guards to like get some helium inflated
balloons for me for my 21st birthday so
I show up to the county jail my mom's
doing a 60 or 90 day stint for a DUI oh
wow
and the guard hands me I'm holding these
helium balloons I multi-color 21
balloons and I had to walk up to the
glass to pick up the phone to have this
conversation when I'm all on 21st
birthday and and you know she's sober
now cuz she's behind behind the glass
there and it brought back all these sort
of memories and there are and I have
closure on it now but in in my waking
hours but I don't dream that much
whenever I have dreams they tend to be
nightmares and they're almost almost
exclusively about my mother and and this
book this is what good fiction does it
it brings out the the emotions that
maybe we didn't want to deal with yeah
help in a way way it was cathartic it
helped me deal with some of those
emotions it brought me back to that
place um I forgot about being there on
my 21st birthday
holding the these ridiculous balloons in
the Warren County Correctional I don't
know who had a worst growing up man no I
sometimes I think no I was more
dysfunctional I I mean it's weird like I
mean you got beat a lot more than I did
so yeah yeah so I don't know but um
pleasure man you know it's funny man
like just going back to the lake getting
over this this this relationship that I
have had a funeral for I've talked to
some friends and I have this one friend
in particular who if I let them go on
they they could go on for an hour about
how you're so great
you don't deserve this and you're such a
lovable guy and people and and those are
very kind words mmm like I appreciate it
but in the same token like I don't feel
like a victim like I am not I'm not
living up to the victim rule right and
what we talked earlier about the victor
versus victim yeah and yes I you I you
could look at my situation your
situation and say you were the victim
and instead I look at it like I can't
believe I got out of that yeah yeah last
week we were talking about that drag so
on the elevat-- song and like I couldn't
imagine like when I was there and
getting over to this side I'm a I feel
like the Victoire like yeah man I I you
know it's like when when LeBron dragged
a bunch of subpar subpar players to the
finals and in 2016 actually dragged them
to winning the final yeah and you
realize like I feel like I've done the
same thing I'm the LeBron of my own life
right getting past those circumstances
yeah man
yeah and that's yeah that's exactly what
I'm getting at man is like I think you
and I instead of you know because it's
easy it is easy to fall into the victim
role but instead of using that as a
source of discontent and allowing you
know negativity or discontent or even
drama into our lives like we take what
has happened to us and yes like coming
through the other side is so much better
than playing victim yeah like owning up
to having not control because you know I
never feel like I'm fully in control but
I am fully in control of my decisions
and like that to me and making good
decisions living a good life like that
is that's the best way to kind of
overcome all those all those you know
times that we were victims of of our
families yeah even if you are a victim
of something I was a victim of a
hit-and-run mmm last year we were on
tour we were in Dayton Ohio I was in a
rental car and I was on feed wire road
and what was that roaming ttan pike yeah
I was driving and this truck just sights
why me I don't know if he was a huge
trucks I don't even know that he
sideswiped me and like totally like
ripped the bumper off
crazy and you know startled me for sure
mm-hmm and I saw oh my god I can't
believe it happened but also oh my god
like it could be worse and and I made it
out of this that's okay and I have to
have to deal with the insurance I have
to pay the deductible because we've
never caught the guy and the police
couldn't find him put guess what it
could have been worse and and I out of
everything I've been able to overcome
yeah sure there'll be other things I
have to overcome - yeah he's something
terrible that will happen at some point
and I need to be able to overcome that
it makes me sad man when I see certain
people I love family members or friends
who they get stuck in and playing the
victim role it's a lot of the times it's
easier to play victim it is easier to
say oh my life isn't good because I'm a
victim of this situation so the rest of
my life
all of the problems that I have it's due
to this one it's easy to like point the
finger and connect Heather everything
back to that that that past sort of
influenced yeah and some some folks who
live in this state of being a victim
they wouldn't know what to do they're
scared of not being a victim yeah they
wouldn't know what to do if they
actually had to take some responsibility
for their own life and yeah just
reiterating taking responsibility feels
so much better than playing the role of
a victim last year I did something with
the rubber band thing that I'm sure
you've probably done twenty-one days
without complaining I think it's like a
Tim Ferriss thing yeah but I tried it
out and like you can't be the victim if
you never complain right right and so
either it got to the point with I didn't
even complain out loud
oh god this is can't believe I'm stuck
in track whatever like after a while
after the the the Pavlovian response
yeah all of a sudden it was like even in
my head if I had the complaint in my
head I would snap myself yeah and then
the complaint started going away in my
own head because I was reprogramming
myself in a way and so if you want to
avoid the victim role and quite often it
starts with stopping the complaining
yeah and it's easy to stop once you
become aware that I'm complaining all
the time yeah some people I mean maybe
they're just you know I'm not trying to
undermine people who were in situations
right now but to get through it
and yes like reprogram how we we view
how we were victimized yes it's it's uh
it's just a much better way to deal with
people who were in obstinance to your
life essentially yeah and the way I
would sum this up basically is yes you
might be a victim you may have been a
victim but you don't have to keep being
a victim in fact you have to stop
feeling like the victim to eventually
become the victor yeah
you